recording artists kaya Jones is also
calling out the music industry kaya we
used to be a member of the Pussycat
Dolls she tweeted this weekend my truth
I wasn't in a girl group I was in a
prostitution ring
oh and we happen to sing and be famous
while everyone who owned us made the
money we reached out to the founder of
the Pussycat Dolls Robin Antin and she
denies what Chi is saying here with
reaction recording artist kaya Jones
actress JC Tracy Lindsey milk cures with
us
kaya how old were you when you first got
into music I was 12 when I first got
signed Wow and how quickly did the
Predators begin to move in well I think
that's the thing they didn't move in
right away from me I didn't receive
anything until I was 18 years old and I
joined the Pussycat Dolls so I think had
I not had a career before that where I
knew that there are people with
integrity it wouldn't have probably been
alarming but it was super alarming
because I had been in the business and
never had any advances and when you say
is a prostitution ring those are strong
words people want to understand this oh
well you know when you have a den mother
from hell that's controlling the girls
manipulating the mind and verbally and
mentally abusive what's the difference
between that and a pimp in order to
control the narrative that's what was
done on a day-to-day basis by miss Anton
and furthermore you know it was a
constant thing of being a you know
attack to the back of cars and innuendos
by different executives she knew and
everyone in the group went through it in
other words you award attack by those
people that had all the power over you
and it was a on a regular basis yeah and
I had to decide for myself my moral
compass I walked away at 21 years old
from a massive conglomerate that was
launching us into orbit how bad could it
be for 21 year old to walk away from her
dreams no I was I knew I was walking I
was standing on a limb Tracy I know you
spent years and and you are on the bold
and the beautiful and and many of these
successful daytime shows and you had a
really you had a horrific time why don't
you tell us what happened well first off
I want to be clear none
my experiences were with my producers
during soaps had lovely producers there
it was prior to that but the
entertainment industry attracts a lot of
women who are looking for validation and
approval and in my case male attention
that I didn't get at home from a father
and so you combine that with wealthy men
who are in a position to advance your
career and I think one of the things I
think that's really important is that at
that time I think I had the false idol
of fame and fortune so I was willing to
sacrifice and do whatever it took for
that and it's interesting how people can
sense that or something because I was
put into so many situations whereas my
friends who maybe weren't as vulnerable
seem to it's you know get around it but
for me it was I I fell into situations
that I was vulnerable to for sure and
you got raped I did not in Hollywood
that was prior at 16 and I think that
what happens is like I it doesn't just
start when you get to Hollywood I think
a lot of it happens before we get there
- a lot it's almost like I was groomed
prior to getting to Hollywood to be the
perfect candidate for these producers
and directors which I did end up falling
victim to which I hate that word victim
but you know it seems like that and all
I was both of you this Traci will start
with you young girls and maybe before
they're 18 around 18 they have dreams
they want to be in the music industry
they want to be on television they want
to be in the movie industry and how
common is this that basically they're
told it's a quid pro quo you want a
movie role you want to get in the band
you want a chance you got to go through
us first
Traci for me it was never that blatant
and obvious though well it was it was
like you knew who could get you a job
you knew
this director was by name you knew who
this producer was and if they're
inviting you to dinner or to something
you're like oh my gosh this is great
because you're thinking it is regarding
your career then you get to dinner and
what do you what is happening in most
cases at dinner they reveal their true
intentions well honestly Shawn a lot of
these dinners I wasn't the only girl
there
there were many it was you know a flock
and it it was just a selection process
I guess Wow and I think that it was you
were actually flattered I was I think it
was like a compliment that you were
chosen and I was just so vulnerable for
wanting that validation and approval you
wrote a great book by the way breaking
the the perfect-10 about the ten
commandments and getting your life back
which I thought was great how frequent
do they play on the ambitions or the
dreams of young people that you have
seen in all the years you've been doing
this yeah well there are good people in
this business too Shawn but ultimately
there are a lot of predators in this
business we've heard the stories from
Cory Feldman we've heard the stories
from Corey Haim we've heard you know Tom
Petty has a song called Joe talking
about you know getting a young girl and
a young boy and making money off of them
and controlling them it is a scary thing
this is what needs to happen is women
need to continue to speak out girls and
my group girls and other groups or in
entertainment period need to speak out
because you can take out the trash at
that last question
good people too are the people that are
creepy well known does everybody know
everybody most know it depends on the
company most know but it depends on the
company not all companies are bad but
there are the select companies that have
men that push things on young girls and
it's you know you're impressionable
you're a woman are you and the political
side of it is you know like the Clintons
you know Hillary Clinton didn't say a
word about her husband now she's
lecturing us on all these issues and she
takes money from these countries that
abuse women abuse the persecute
Christians and Jews and kill gays and
lesbians and then she's some
sanctimoniously will lecture
everybody else and and Hughes Mitt
Romney of misogyny because he had he had
literally resumes of women he wanted to
hire that you know slander him neither
one of you deserve that I'm glad you're
speaking out and hopefully this horrible
practice stops we appreciate it thank
you thanks